this is a production of Cornell
University
the title of my talk today is the malice
collection in the US national insurance
system here to show you a publication
found a global crop biodiversity trap
trust two years ago as you can see that
in North America very few actually the
crop will use and we eat actually came
from North America so for longest time
us diploma actually start collecting
germ plasm material from around the
globe as early as lay 1700 and then in
nineteen eighteen sixty two President
Lincoln create a US Bureau of
Agriculture the current day USDA
and also signed the Morrill land-grant
University at which is very important
related to Cornell University and then
move forward 30 years in 1898 for major
even happened
internal plant exploration activity
first is the office of a seat and the
plant introduction the current plan
exchange office was established by by
Fairchild and swing go at that time then
the year the introduction garden for the
tropical plan was established in Miami
Florida that's the first repository in
this system and then also at that year
new Henson was hire as a first plan
Explorer and he also introduced the
first plant material pi0 zero zero zero
one
Branka Brassica OAC from russia at that
year also introduced by Handsome the
plain introductions later station later
was a established at chico california in
1904 and also in savannah georgia and at
glendale maryland in nineteen nineteen
nineteen and they in 1946 based on the
research and marketing at for plan
introduction was established including
the North East region the NI project
station at Geneva New York in July 1948
here's a picture showing some of the
pioneer in the plant exploration
activity de pierre cha in the Walters
Wingo who was actually both of 26 years
so
a recent graduate from Kansas State
University in major in pathology I
believe and then Johansson as a first
plan Explorer later he actually become a
professor of South Dakota stay for
longest time for over 40 years one of
the most famous plan explorer Frank
Meyer and also dr. Charlie Rick at UC
Davis he spent almost entire career
collecting tomato germ plasm in the and
E in the South South America and also
her Omo who introduced a lot of great
material in a 1960 from the meditator
Eugene reaching into into the u.s. also
awesome company spent a lot of time
several decade in Central America
collecting a lot of food germ plasm
material including avocado here's a
photo of an interpreter standing in
front of a large wall mouse material in
changshan region of Chinese Turkestan in
1911 this photo was taken by Frank Meyer
here's some photo of some of the Apple
and also crabapple foo in the market in
Xi'an China in 1914 this photo also
taken by Frank Meyer
are currently there's 20 locations
throughout the US that either a
laboratory or repository dedicated the
national plan germplasm system including
right here in Geneva New York at Geneva
New York there's actually two Research
Unit the first is the plant genetic
resources unit the PGR you die in Kuni
the sea crab or the wretched world germ
pausing collection my colleagues on the
bay talk about the collection last
october also here in the horticultural
stamina and then we have the kono crab
which is the apple co hardy grape and
tart cherry and also we have a program
on the Appaloosa breeding program led by
dr. Gennaro Fazio and then we have
another research unit is the grape
genetic research unit Gigi are you there
working on a genetics and genome of wait
here's just showing you some of the
photo from 1903 skip one for the kono
repository you started actually back in
1974 a discussion at the a citrus
American Society horticultural workshop
talking about the need for a fruit and
nut crop repository system and then
further discussion in 1908 late 1970 and
then bill Cermak who was a supervisor
from operation was higher on board in
1983 it was actually still working on
Geneva and then in 1984 my predecessor
phil force line the first curator for
the collection came on bore and planting
of the grape and also apple collection
actually beginning 1983 and the first
planting was in 1986 the tart cherry
collection original was housed at the
davis repository in california it was
moved to Geneva in 1995 due to better
growing environment here to show you
some of the photo the view of the
collection in the mccarthy farms house
just a nursery just started in 1985 few
from 2000
seven and few from two years ago doing
the Boomtown for all the tartaric
collection over there here to show you
some the photo of some of the diversity
of the apple collection we have over
there in Geneva New York for the
establishment of the mouth collection in
mid-1980
actually started by donation of a lot of
Apple material from different program
and while the most important Apple
breeding program of Cornell University
actually led by dr. Roger Roger way at
that time here's a photo showing some
other older professor at that time in
the Horticulture Department over there I
believe this is dr. Roger way there and
also material from the Purdue rocker
Serena no Apple breeding program the PRI
Apple breeding program also a lot of
material from Washington State
University agriculture Canada different
arbor readin plenty of introduction
station kvass koalas the repository also
the United Kingdom the British Apple
collection from the loan ashton research
station and then different material from
Australia China Germany Israel Japan
Madeleine Swiss learn also Russia here's
a photo of the PRI breeding program
that's dr. Julius jenkin Purdue
University and he is still very active
Society horticultural science here like
to show you the distribution of all the
water model species or worldwide as you
can see majority of the wild mouse
materials actually locally in Asia
especially in China it is well belief
that models actually origin from
Southwest China then you moved north to
central and northern part of the China
and then continued moving on to the west
follow the Silk Road through history
eventually reach Central Asia while
species opposite over there at melosa
Vesey and then eventually reach your
Europe for example malice or intolerance
foreign tina and also malice of estrus
European crabapple in North America is
actually for Mallos while species
material on the East Coast into Canada
we have malice corneria most insist in
the Midwest and also Mollison just 40 at
the southern crabapple and then in the
Pacific Northwest we have malice Ruska
on the modern-day Apple malice the my
cicada is actually a hybrid species he
has most of the material deploy with
Sabba komasan 17 shadow coma song and
was their origin actually came from
mallow sebasi in the central asia which
we will talk a little bit more and also
from the european crabapple those are
the check out sorry those actually the
chinese species actually we don't really
have them in the collection so that's we
hope in the future we can get more
material from china also for other area
over there here is a study we we publish
three years ago looking at the conserved
sequence of corpus genome of the 31
different mouse species and using 460
accession in general a lot of asian
species they all group together
especially those material from china and
then as you all know also notice the
mallas fur scarf on the Pacific
Northwest is actually also closely
related to the a lot asian species
therefore it is well believed that model
fusca actually came from Asia through
the land bridge when the land was still
frozen and the rich Alaska eventually
come to British Columbia Washington
Oregon and Northern California and then
for the modern-day Apple models the my
cicada and also it's for general species
they also actually closer related to the
Asian species and then there were we
have there's a group of Asian material
they are actually more tropical for ten
example the malos inland ences is
actually the best example the morphology
and everything of all this
Tyrael is really different on this most
of the Asian while malice material so
phylogenetically they kind of group
together by themselves and then we have
a one very unique material Maoist Omari
it's actually located in place like a V
nan Miramar and also into Taiwan the
history of this material are still being
debated but it's possible this material
might be actually closer related to
Pyrus instead of malice so someone some
researcher are working on that and then
we have some models material in the
meditation region for example of foreign
tina in northern Italy but I believe
there's some other one-mile species in
Europe for example in in a Highland of
Lebanon and also there's wall species in
in Sicily they are really isolated they
are kind of maybe have a unique
evolution also domestication history
among those isolated species material
and then of course we have the North
American three wild species in East
Coast out of the North American
continent here just showing a corner
gram timeframe differentiation between
the different wild model species in this
particular study they actually use two
North American wild species the model
Sciences and also malas angustifolia you
can see this two material actually is
most ancient compared with all the while
model species out there but they are
located in North America and they
separated from all the rest of the
maoist material between by about 20 to
40 million years so how these three
species came about in the North America
still is one of the major puzzle at
least in my mind soon after the
establishment of the mollusk collection
based on the donation from all the
programs basically from all over the US
and also from around the globe the
researcher actually realized there's
really either need trying to collect
more while MAOIs material and therefore
in 1987 professor
who is also working in Canarsie
he started expiration and malformed
Alice fusca in Pacific Northwest and
followed by dr. Elizabeth Dickinson who
was the first PhD student of death toll
and for her PhD at Cornell University he
collect she collected a lot of material
and gas podía corneria also I wanna
insist and study their genetic
relationship and then starting 1989 93
95 96
professor herb Alan Koh who was a
professor at pathology department at
Cornell University in Geneva together
with my predecessor Phil first line and
also researcher found different
institution even from different country
they went over to Central Asia
especially in Casas tend to collect a
model sebacic material for different
time and then in 1997 they carry out one
of the exploration in China collects
seven different Wow model species
material and followed by one exploration
in in Russia from all Soren tell us and
the more in in Turkey for mouse or
Teletoon
and then after almost 16 year hiatus in
exploration activity I restarted
exploration activity in 2015 by
collecting mass and gas folia in the
southern US we continue doing so since
this is surveyed down by once again by
crop diversity trust and also our
colleague L VOC the USDA laboratory for
Colin Corrado they did a survey for all
the apple collection around the globe
here to show you the top 10 Apple
collection internal their number and
also there were models species
representation in the collection as you
can see at that time the PGR your
collection is the largest internal the
total number and also in terms of the
diversity of the WHA model species
material here
so I a borrow from dr. Peter Brady who
is a national program leader Oh planned
germplasm also genome within the USDA
ARS he gave the priority for all the Jim
germplasm resources management all the
repository in general basically for all
the repository our number one priority
is the maintenance also the safeguarding
of the material we have in the
collection and for the sea crab and the
row crop that involve a lot of
regeneration work and also safekeeping
out of documentation also data
associated with the accession in the
collection all those three activity
considered number one internal priority
and next is actually acquisition
this is leaders who exploration exchange
of material for the country all within
the US and the third party is the
distribution on the material to all the
stakeholder by including general public
and also researcher which I will talk a
little bit more and next party is
actually characterization also
evaluation of all the accession in the
collection and the next is actually
enhancement what that mean is trying to
make crosses events the generation so
you can have new trade or disease
resistant into events material that can
be used by breeder and then finally is
trying to carry out research in support
all the preceding priorities most
specifically for the models collection
our number one priority of course the
maintenance and the safeguarding of the
material we do that by have a field
collection of all the trees different
material all different variety and also
while species material we use also use
Co freezer -20 freezer just to store the
seeds we collected and also we have
using cryopreservation of dormant Bawa
of the malleus at the USDA National
Center for genetic resources
preservation unit a full column Corrado
and next is acquisition we're doing a
lot of those activities through
exchanges also explorations on malice
during pause in the US and also from
around the globe and next its
distribution for mouse we usually
district between 4000 to 6000 sample
each year that including winter Dolman
Babu some above pollen flower fusilli
fanned DNA sample and then next user
care organization we carry a lot of
different morphologies study also
genetic study of all our session in the
collection and all the information they
are store at germplasm resources
information network database the current
day green global database and finally we
will carry out a lot of outreach
actively trying to increase the public
awareness of the value also importance
of the malleus collection here to show
you some history for the mouse
exploration started by in central asia a
lot of Russian scientists actually start
in study the wild malice in Central Asia
as early as early as we call it back in
1796 all the way in early 1900 the
famous plan geneticists the claw of
Babylon actually he first time explore
the wild Apple forest in Central Asia in
Casas tan first guy in 2019 29 together
with waha the planks were west over from
usda at that time and then later on
professor dental of and other scientists
on the cosna stan academy of science
they explore explore the wild mouse in
the region and also studied them for
several decades
here is a photo showing the first
exploration Beauvoir went to central
asia the apple forest the first time in
1929 here he is and oh here is actually
Westover who is a planned Expo Explorer
from usda accompanied him at the same
time
some photo showing Bob Lowe actually
came to eat chicken ooh you're in 1932
to attend the sixth International
Congress of genetics this is right here
and here is actually a photo of a
Barbara McClintock right here and at
that time he came to New York he also
brought with him two paintings of a bar
apple from Casa Stan and Kristen is to
pending actually still housed at a
Cornell library and this two pending was
actually presented to Professor
Wellington who was a director for the
Experimental Station at Geneva at that
time I want to show you I pay attention
to this particular painting of this
Apple so follow up on that later here's
a map showing all the exploration in
Central Asia by my predecessor and
professor herb Allan Coe and other folks
basically most of the exploration
actually is in the country of Casas then
a three different time location actually
in three other former sofa Soviet
republic so altogether they are 40 fun
trip in 89 93 95 and 96 they have 12
different major sides and also they
collect something they call 44 elite
melosa Vesely these are the trees 1a in
the field they look wonderful maybe they
show resistant to diseases or draw or
some other unique food quality therefore
they also collect a bowl of those 44
material bringing it back to the US
through the quarantine system but
majority of the material they collected
actually the open pollinated seeds
altogether they collect 894 see your
session from mouse-over see in that come
in four different trip and after all
together they collect over 130,000 seeds
after returned to the US over 40,000 of
those seeds actually was sent out to all
the Apple researcher in the u.s. also
around the globe at that time
up till now over a third 39,000 all
those seeds from the origin exploration
still store in the freezer for Colin
and over 50,000 of those he actually
store at the freezer in Geneva also in
the last ten year
we're being collect the open pollinated
seeds over 200,000 of those Opie seeds
from Alistair versus heating block we
call those a mountain you know desire
sea because thanks to Michael Pollan's
book a lot of people asking for the
material so when people send us a
request we'll send a package of 25 open
policy of massive se was the instruction
how to stratify and germinate the sea so
you can have your own while Marcy from
Central Asia here just show you quickly
some of the photo and as mentioned
earlier about a particular painting on
their expression in the nineteen
nineteen eighty and ninety one
particulars Apple really similar to the
drawing by all the way by presented by
rebel all to professor wouldn't and at
that time some of the photo exploration
in China in 1997 exploration in Turkey
the rel they take over Turkey at that
time and then in 99 in 2015
I restarted exploration activity Geneva
New York we see funding once again
founded by playing strange office at
national germplasm resource the
laboratory was a 16 day trip almost
5,000 mile driving from New York down to
Arkansas Mississippi Louisiana and
Alabama and came back I was able to
color over 7,000 ORAC found 38 different
trees also some of the leaf sample at
that time here's a mark our who's a
professor at University of Southern
Mississippi who was actually also a
graduate from Cornell University he was
very helpful for this trip and then
follow-up
exploration once again in the Arkansas
Mississippi Louisiana in 2016 almost
5000 open policy from 18 different trees
and also
mobile material at that time and last
year together with the Julian group we
actually went to Pennsylvania to collect
Mouse coronary or material were able to
collect over 12,000 open policy found 29
different treats also 11 different
location actually we found there's a lot
more mouths coronary trees in
Pennsylvania so a lot more sample could
be collected maybe in the future
a week later I went out to another trip
by myself to collect Mouse corneria and
also mala Sciences in misses in Michigan
Illinois Iowa and also Missouri wow the
perks of this treat trip actually was
following the footsteps of elizabeth
dickinson 30 year beforehand and i
visited 22 location that elizabeth
actually collected back in the late 1984
CH initely 20 out of 22 side that he
collectors some time he heard
description were saying there's over 100
trees in particular location
all those 20 20 side all the way maula
street are all gone due to a lot of
development in the midwest so some of
the lesson have learned from the mouse
expiration so far in the US the first
thing is trying to understand the role
of the target species play in the
ecological setting it's actually very
important to understand its location the
age of the environment it's also
affecting the growth habit of the tree
its morphology and also how reliable is
the herbarium sample that we base on for
collection a lot of older harboring
sample by knowing the possible location
environment this species could be then
actually you can eliminate some of those
location most likely the tree sample
will not be there
there's actually a lot of site they will
loss especially during the last 30 years
due to urban development especially
seems like that's the case in the
Midwest and also in the South actually
don't do to a clear cutting logging
practice sometime they were coming chop
off entire block of trees including some
other freestanding wild mouse material
also seems climate change could be a
problem
hurricane in the south sometimes
flooding actually also down there some
other tree they've been around for maybe
ten year I've seen that in 2015 but on
2016 why return to the same side almost
trees along a mile track actually on
both I or all flooded all the tree just
just got killed in that year and also a
lot of land management decision
especially al owal malice issues
material they are very thorny so in a
lot of the park location people actually
will cut a tree off because the tree
probably are too phony because of that
reason but I believe there's still a lot
of wild mouse materials still exist
especially in poverty force State Park
Nature Reserve and even some of the
actually on private land so but they're
getting more difficult to find but I
think we should try to spend effort
trying to get more before they a
complete disappear then talk about why
we're trying to collect or preserve the
wild germ plasm material especially the
wild mouse material on a global scale
a lot of material also their natural
habitat a loss in the last decade or so
and also last half-century due to a lot
of agricultural development changes and
also the changes also a lot of urban
development also a lot of human activity
especially in some less developed
countries such as a far route getting
it's really a problem the people just
chopped off all the wild mouse in that
case also a lot of animal grazing
environment degradation
climate change could be an issue also
land management decision and also in
some location especially like in Europe
that's the case for European crabapple
mallow semesters the gene flow and also
pollen contamination found a co2 based
species really become a serious issue in
some case the study showed that 60% of
the while the open policy you collect
from sixty percent of population
actually all contaminated by mouse
domestic you domesticate a pollen so
that's a serious issue in Europe
sometimes due to new paths and disease
and also new invasive species so a lot
of problem also climate change has been
documented in Central Asia and causes
for example in the last almost hundred
years temperature has risen post in the
winter time also during the springtime
here some study from China for example
in the 50-year period 80% of the wild
mouse material in Shenyang China were
all lost due to variety of the reason
well the major reason surprisingly over
there is actually over harvests of wire
fruit the local resident actually they
like to collecting the material so in
the last two year the researcher
actually trying to collect more material
but they couldn't because before they
showed up all of whom were gone
collected by local resident so that's a
serious problem and also there's a study
in 2014
showing that firewood getting it's
especially serious issue in Central Asia
a lot of our malice material also a lot
of food tree material simple issues
between laws so they can be complete
down in the next 50 to 150 years earlier
some target of a future Mouse
exploration I'm going to collect more
common area in Ohio this year my
colleague gehlbach she's trying to carry
our exploration for mouse tamari in
North East bean on this this for next
year maybe more angustifolia in the
southern US and also mouse corner
in West Virginia in two years and then
there's a lot of much material in
different places as all wish lists we're
trying to collect hopefully in the next
five to ten years besides go collected
planned germplasm material either in the
u.s. also around the globe we also do a
lot of importation of the models German
past material from other country into
the US all this material we bought in
has to go to the USDA APHIS quarantine
system it has to be cling up over there
then were released to us every year we
receive between 10 to 20 years session
from the AFIS sometime war in recent
year for example the model sebasi elite
concentration was imported and also a
lot of cider apple for northern spain
was introduced actually by professor
year merwin before he retired two years
ago a lot of cider from England Greg
over here and a lot of different variety
and rusa material from variety of
different country in the last five years
and also all this material take a
several year to go through the
quarantine system all the most extreme
example are two of the mouse eally
material was collected in 1996
expiration welcome will just release one
months ago we got noticed on Ava's
saying after 22 year the material is
finally release there's one more
actually still in quarantine
maybe next year so we'll wait I see what
happened so altogether in the last five
years we introduced over 100 6:162
clones and also we collect over adding
360 accession to the malleus collection
in the last five years we also have been
selecting a lot in a while seeding
material and after the permanent
collection we had over 300
accession to the permanent collection
last year so all together almost 800
different
new accession will add to the collection
in the last five years here to show you
show you why the aphids quarantine
system takes so long while the major
reason is it has to go through
biological indexing if there is any
disease being found then they have the
dose to a tissue culture process then
goes through a thermal therapy and then
it goes who's she tipped grafting micro
grafting of the material and then being
retest again before they can
provisionally release to us then we'll
based on field observation for
additional two to three years before
they can fully release so normally this
process take about at least five years
but in the extreme case we have a
material being a quarantine for 23 year
now so last year there is the
interesting development the global crop
diversity trust together with millennion
sea bank at the rope on kenny garden in
Kew England they have an ongoing project
they are collecting 29 crop wild
relatives in 24 different country
including the wild malice this project
was founded by governme
Norway and for the malleus collection
lady sigh all the sea they collect
actually one-third of all the seeds will
stay at the country of origin the other
ones there of the C would be stored at a
seed bank in Kew garden and after quite
a intense discussion for almost two
weeks they made a decision the remaining
one-third of all the while mono sealer
collected will come to Geneva for
evaluation also characterization this
including Wow miles from seven different
countries some of the material from this
country will never have that in our
collection so it's very interesting and
exciting hopefully to get the hands on
this material from seven different
country next one to tell you some of the
story we're getting involved in the last
five year for example in 2016 two years
ago we propagate a whole bunch of 28
crap
from blown two different Walmart species
some other hybrid species from the US
National Arboretum they have a new
director director over there and he made
a decision they going to remove their
entire Mouse collection so some of the
material were able to rescue and come to
Geneva before they will completely
remove and
in back in 2017 last year while the
material is a Martha Helene Anna from
from China it's actually located at USDA
Chico station since 1914 was originally
collected by Frank Meyer and once again
also in San Shi area he collected
material in 1914 January and then sent
to Chico station in in March the
material actually has been near for the
last almost 100 years okay somehow Holly
from the national plunger deposit system
Garrigan our Kenard and also Karen Wilin
I was able to go to Chico station
identify the material and then the
bubble was sent to us for preservation
was very interesting this is actually
multi Pato cattle layer pedo of
crabapple material Wow Apple material so
it will be interesting to see how he
looks like right here in Geneva New York
and also Karen William and also Derek
Renard they also went to a former USDA
station introduction field station in
Cheyenne Wyoming they found a whole
bunch of Mouse material has been around
since about 1920 and 1930 so they're
able to rescue about 11 material and
collect the Babu and send to us for
propagation some of them several
crabapple rack crabapple material from
Canada
we caught that Lake series crabapple and
also three different wild mouse material
either originally came from China
collect by Dorset in 1927 or France's
from China
and also one material found from Europe
so those material rescue or come to
Geneva in New York next I want to talk a
little bit about the maintenance of the
Mallos collection basically all the
variety we have a trees in the field and
also we have a core collection from
collection away have we store the seed -
20 freezer we also have the doorman Bawa
in the cairo preservation here is
showing some photo from the center in
for Colorado we test the viability by
budding and then for our routine
maintenance of a safeguarding of the
material we'll do a lot of weeding
spraying a nursery operation also
pruning doing a wintertime here just
showing the list of all the collection
we have we have over basic 7,000 our
session right now in the total
collection all the permanent material
have a tag showing all the information
or photo of the collection here's my
predecessor fuel force lawyer and dr.
herb Alan Koh in 2013 during a bloom
time
here she's showing some of the data from
our distribution record in the last
eight year basically between 2010 in
2017 with this review basically this is
a number of requests we got in the last
three year you can see in the last three
year we really have a high number of
requests actually 2016 was a record
number of requests but was the total
number of sample was not a record but we
believe that 2018 Maivia record we're
doing a lot of characterization work all
the information about the material
actually store in the green Globo
database we also do a lot of study about
the chemical composition disease and
information all that is all asked for
the Green global database we're also in
the last 20 year did a tremendous amount
of work in study the wild mouse germ
plasm material basically a lot of
disease really the work and also study
of the material different trait this is
one particular materials actually able
to discover a new brand new highly
resistant material against blue male
Mouse here just showing inoculation
seven-day after inoculation in resistant
material versus the susceptor material
it's a significant contrast between the
reaction after inoculation with blue
mouse and two major kill TL control this
tray will map in chromosome number three
and commercial number ten and then we do
a lot of other study a different tray
with a lot of different cooperator well
also
provide a lot of material for different
researcher everywhere well the best
example is actually there's a
publication by Velasco in 2010 the
genome of the domestic apple actually in
that study they used seventies for a
session actually 46 of those actions
actually all came from Geneva collection
so and the last two year alone there's
about 18 publication we are directly
involved with seven of those the using
are to imply some material to to carry
out the research we did the GPS work
since 2012 did the G wasps analysis
using the GPS data also we did a
extensive resequencing study which after
luncheon and at the fail the Thompsons
research in here right here in Geneva in
in New York in Ithaca actually study the
history domestication of modern day
Apple here's a showing diagrams actually
two step process for processing
full-size increased one happened before
domestication process what actually
happened during the domestication
process in Central Asia a lot of work
who was together with Gregg in the last
few years
searching for the hard cider for New
York which is become while the fastest
growing in sector of the industry for
alcoholic beverage industry in the US
Gregor's studied the malleus collection
we have looking for the best material
also Spanish cider material also right
now in the collection we're trying to
look into some of the wild mouse
material this is a photo of actually a
cider made from a red flash material
almost looked like a red wine then we
are currently actually supporting
actually nineteen different research
ongoing research a lot of them long time
cooperation for example with dr. Susan
brown apple wing program at Cornell
University
and then also the Apple rooster breeding
program and a lot of different work in
the last couple of years people from
Michigan State and Purdue University dr.
Kenan sue right here in Geneva doing a
lot of fruit quality work and also tree
architectural trades analysis for doing
a lot of sequencing work with different
researchers from different institutions
from Harvard University from John
institution in England some folks for
Australia also some disease work and
also insect monitor work and also with
Greg on the cider work and also we start
relying on Chen on the bitter raw
evaluation in the last few years we
spent over there also right now with dr.
Abbas Khan who's a new faculty relative
the new faculty Geneva and the plant
pathology working on different disease
related issue and also a lot of we're
supporting a lot of cider variety
testing right now because cider is
getting so hot a lot of people
interesting so we're studying actually
supporting material for study in
actually places like Arizona Georgia
California Maine Michigan Montana New
Mexico New Year of course Washington's
day and also West Virginia but study a
lot of those material so then we have
some uniques requests in the last couple
years especially I think this request
from the Smithsonian trying to get the
bark tissue for Native all species from
Japan but study the yellow dye in the
use in a traditional Japanese painting
that's also very unique are we doing a
lot of outreach a lot of people visit
our collection Hobart whaling space
college classes several classes every
year and also CBS Sunday morning Mo
Rocca our last year October visitor
collection
Cornell plant breeding courses 4060
actually come to the collection every
year in September
and also a lot of researcher from
different country from China from Brazil
and from many other country also the
grower extension personnel come to the
collection all the time in the last five
year basically over 1,500 visitors
actually come to the collection 79
different group and classes so it's very
interesting finally I want to thank a
lot of people involved in the project
and it's a very long list here just
showing some of the photo of some of the
folks we work together on the project
any question thank you
[Applause]
sorry I have to rush you the latter half
of the dog so looking into the future
type of question the first wise entry
you should that there is a service out
there how many members are in that
exception I don't quite remember I have
to go back to look sorry about that
Allen was asking copass DNA sequence
study of the malleus relationship we
have a service our group so he's asking
how many sessions in our group I don't
quite remember so I have to go back to
look I'm sorry yes look into the future
how do you think the future are you
should too the research needs in the
post genomics era because currently
kidyou largely keeps a lot to treats
from exception that's absolutely fine
but for any other type of let's say you
know have low mix or two wraps or just
you know don't provide good information
do you think this situation and they're
gonna get improved in the future in the
next few years the question la don't
just ask is how we're going to adopt
maybe in the future regarding currently
that most of a collection in the field
we only have a single tree
representation so that's probably enough
for genomic genetic related study but
that is probably not enough for
additional kind of Physiology or other
kind of study so we have any idea how
we're going to move forward in the
future regarding this actually that's
actually quite an extensive discussion
on the continuing basis for himself and
actually also
for the entire college germplasm repoter
repository system we're facing a
limitation on the resources and also on
the land also on the personnel so it's
very difficult trying to have more than
one copy of the trees most of the people
most of the repository actually have
more than one copy the reason we go is a
single tree is because we do have a very
good bio preservation backup system
right now about 95 percent of all the
permanent collections we have in the
collection actually we they are back up
in the Cairo preservation that we'll
call in Colorado so that's what the
reason we go with a single tree
representation I think moving forward
there's discussion trying to get some
funding support maybe trying to we have
Quaid maybe a new course election with a
better representation of the entire
diversity and also including some of the
more important with variety found risa
in the last 20 in the last 30 years the
core right now we have it's almost 30
years old so a lot of information
different selection could be including
maybe this new court so if that's the
direction we're going with then
hopefully we can maybe have duplicate of
the new court maybe two or three of
those duplication either planning in
Geneva additional signs in Eva or maybe
trying to work with other university
such as the Washington State University
and also maybe it was kearneysville West
Virginia they also have land over there
so we have a copy of the new core over
there so if we can do that then we can
probably at least minimize some of this
single representation issue for the
future and so tap into people's
obsession over apples heaven
engaging the public and some of these
recall it says I am project where they
could report to you any what they think
is an ancient tree on their property for
a long railroad folds like Hill Road
connecting east to west or east asylum
because I've heard about this in
Washington that there was a nursery
where there was it's all a bunch of
ancient tree varieties and they
primarily collected it from abandoned
arms and railroad sites and so I
wondered if you could engage them you
know people around the United States to
give you the seeds or reports you were
at either Lily Union right actually
there's a you're correct there's a lot
of public interests in the apple
specifically I'm something we call the
heirloom apple variety in the in North
America actually I went to well the
first heirloom Apple meeting last year
in Maine so there's actually a different
group especially very active group in in
Maine in Colorado in Washington there's
actually story just came up from
Washington stay about discovery of find
new I heirloom Apple variety and also
we're working was a history professor
actually in Georgia he is working on
fifteen heirloom apple variety he kind
of rediscover over there so yes we got
constant requests actually by the
heirloom folks but it's very hard
because we're limited space so the lot
of private actually institutions
stepping in in this regard for example
the sea saver exchange in Iowa the
currently their collection for heirloom
Apple is only about four hundred four
hundred variety they actually plan to
increase their collection of a variety
up to fifteen hundred then there's a
Southern heritage apple orchard in Oscar
aina your collection currently have
about 2,000 heirloom Apple variety and
the grouping Maine Maine Heritage
Foundation maybe they currently have a
collection of a three
400 heirloom apple variety and then
there's more this going on in Colorado
and Washington State and also actually
there's some interests I got phone call
and contact from some of the folks from
New York actually just two weeks ago on
West first Empire of New York and also
founder pardon your people asking allow
this question we're trying to help we're
trying to engage we also live in what we
could do so that's a very challenge but
will help them for example if they want
to engage in genetic study so they need
to stand the variety usually they will
come to us will provide a sample for
them to do comparison genetic study from
sample we actually do also the hair
heritage Apple group actually they are
considering trying to come to Geneva for
their any meeting actually this year
they want me to chair the organization
committee so we'll see how that goes
thanks pastor child for a fascinating
presentation thank you thank you this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu